[Music]
let's go to ken in spokane what's up ken
how we doing
hey dr john thanks for taking my call i
appreciate you and your team's work that
you guys do thank you so much i
appreciate me not so much my team but
just kidding they're awesome they're
incredible man hey thank you so much i'm
glad you're in our gang ken what's up
man how can i help
well i i'm in a undecisive part of life
me too man let's do this
okay so
um i recently divorced well about three
years ago now my divorce was final for
almost 30 years of marriage to the day
of the divorce actually hey let's just
stop something um
okay that's a lot
that's a death that's a death i mean
that's a heavy loss what happened after
30 years
well it got real crazy towards the end
um basically my my ex
struggled with things in her life
she
hid for years that she was
bisexual
and hid that i just thought she was a
farm girl you know
and that sort of thing and she hid that
for years
and then about five years before the
divorce
she developed breast cancer so we went
through the
that she made it out the other end we
did
good there
things really changed with the
medications for treatment you know and
radiation
and i don't know if near-death
experience brought the
hidden
thing with her out after that you know
like a life change deal that made her
switch to wanting to come out and
and go that direction yeah
so there was a lot of uh maybe she got
to the end and said i'm not hiding
anymore this is gonna be the way this is
like life's too short or whatever yeah
yeah yeah so so does she leave you for a
woman does she leave you and say hey
this is gonna be who i am and you can be
in her i mean how did that end yes
yes so she yeah so she she
was secretive and started seeing uh a
couple actually
so she was cheating this is so this
isn't this is less about sexuality this
is infidelity she's cheating on you
right and
her rationale was it's not cheating
because it's with a lady and not a guy
you know all kinds of different things
okay gotcha cheating is cheating
cheating so okay
okay so
sorry go ahead go ahead
i'm a fixer so i was doing everything to
save my marriage you know i got married
in front of god and it was for better
for worse so yeah
i battled and tried to save for
a long time and i think i sacrificed
myself along the process yeah absolutely
yeah
it sounds like there was two hurting
people
trying to heal each other and themselves
at the same time so that's a hard
situation man
and so
30 years
you get to the end and all of a sudden
whoa and then you met somebody new
yeah i actually went to kindergarten
together um when we were young yeah
so you're telling me there's a chance
all right
wow okay how do y'all reconnect the
internets
so i i was finalizing the divorce and
selling of the house
the ex had moved away and took a
different position a different job and i
was left with
selling the property and you know
dividing the assets and that sort of
thing and and going through it
which she never wanted me to do
and she wanted to have a kind of a
double life so to speak and it wasn't
going to work for me or her um
but yeah so she reached out to me and
and i think she could kind of see that i
may have been going through some she got
an indication or a feeling she was
volunteering at a a boys camp
as a nurse and um
she reached out and said hey is this the
the guy we went to school together lived
next door to me and and i said i said
yeah and we just started connecting and
next door neighbors it's like dawson's
creek man this is incredible okay so
fast forward it's been a couple years
now you say three years
yeah we're just we're approaching three
years now we've been dating for about
two
so fun good for you you know the whole
divorce with the x took five years to
kind of process wow everything out it
was a slow
trudge but yeah so we're dating but now
i'm
you know i'm like you know this guy's
amazing you know and and uh we've done
some things together travel with some
friends and things like that
and uh
you know she is divorced years prior uh
quite a few years prior than me and of
course all of our kids are gone out of
the house
um
so i'm like you know i've had some of
some of our friends say gosh you're
gonna marry this guy you're gonna put a
ring on her finger and all this stuff
you know yeah she's amazing and then i
tiny little
silly things you know and everyone has
those
glitches you know and uh myself included
and it's like in the back of my head i'm
like is this a red flag because i think
i didn't see so many in my first
marriage and i'm having a hard time
putting that baggage down
and looking at this new and it's
starting to come up in the back of my
head and i'm like
what am i waiting for um
but i'm so
cautious of messing it up yeah yeah so
i'm undecisive um i've talked about this
i talked about this about a year ago a
lot when we had several calls
in similar calls about infidelity
and
i think
one of the
hardest things if not the hardest thing
when somebody cheats on you
there is the obvious breach you brought
somebody else into this relationship
you violated a core covenant that we
agreed we were in this together
that's huge that's a that's a major like
the ground you're walking on is
fractured it's unstable
but i think equal
maybe if not worse long-term damage
is what you're experiencing
which is you lose trust in ken
how in the world did i miss this for so
long or
most of the time
i knew something was up and i didn't say
anything
and
people
will heal from the violation they can
they can outsource it this person made
those choices to cheat on me with
somebody else and i got to live with
that
and they made choices i can be at peace
with the fact that somebody else made
choices that hurt me
but what's really hard to heal from is
i don't trust me anymore
and your brain when when you are out of
trust your brain takes over and here's
what your sweet brain is doing for you
because it loves you ken
it is looking for every possible threat
because i'm not it's not doing that
again
it's not going through five years of
hell because that almost killed us last
time i'm not doing that again
so this is just your body your biology
remembering trauma and saying whoa whoa
what are you doing what do you do you
know what i mean
it feels you getting back on the same
roller coaster that almost killed you
last time
it doesn't mean every roller coaster is
unsafe in fact the opposite most roller
coasters are great
but it almost killed you once and your
body remembers and so you i want to hear
you to hear me sick in you're not crazy
your body's doing exactly what it should
be doing which is trying to look out for
you
the real question you gotta get to is
is she the right is she right for me
have you been on
uh have you been healing
do you trust ken
and more importantly do you trust her so
answer that for me is this right
i definitely trust her okay um
does she know that you have that your
body's
she knows you've got apprehension does
she know how bad you felt burned
yeah i think so i think i think she does
because let's let's let's own this you
walked through
cancer with somebody
you walked through somebody who almost
died
you wept with her you held her
throughout the night you
went to appointments with her
you figured out insurance and bills and
all stuff y'all went through stuff
together and then on the other side she
said you're not my guy
have you fully grieved that because that
sucks
yeah it was it was tough and then to
turn around and
go through years of
her infidelity thinking that okay this
is a phase and she's going to come back
around yeah and be that same person she
never was and then i had to
had had to file the divorce for me yeah
um
and uh she had a great setup man she's
got somebody that's gonna ride out
cancer with her and then she can go
have her romantic flings with other
places she had a perfect setup going
yeah i mean even her own mother told me
what are you doing you know she's having
her cake and eating it too and you're
sitting here why she's doing things that
are wrong yeah
and yeah and uh and i i went to a
counselor i did do that and i walked
through that process with the counseling
she was amazing good good good good i'm
proud of you really that's good and so
here
i i just want you to respect your body
and so when i'm innocent and i haven't
been through what you've been through
what you've been through is brutal i
don't want you to underestimate the
trauma and sometimes we live in event we
live things
and we because we're living them
it's not as headline it's not
sensational it's not quote unquote over
there it's us in the middle of it and we
don't fully recognize the trauma that
our body took on for us and your body's
been through a lot
and now
your heart fell in love and your brain
is going oh
i know this script i know this story
and so
bringing that into
acknowledging it oh there's my body
pointing out a flaw and you being able
to go
thank you for trying to take care of me
but i'm good now because this one's
awesome she's awesome
and you begin to let your brain know i'm
in control i'm good i'm getting back on
this roller coaster on purpose because
it's super fun it's gonna be amazing and
we're gonna get whipped around a little
bit like all roller coasters but it's
gonna be a blast
and then eventually your body goes cool
you're driving we're back
but you got to practice that um
so i'm kind of i'm smiling here
do you love this this woman
i do yeah
so
let yourself say it out loud
do you want to marry her
i do
is that scaring you to death in my head
it seems like yes it absolutely because
i'm afraid of messing it up
what
because you think you messed up the last
one
well i couldn't fix it i think that's
what i can't get out of my head and i
and i
you know i'm being a fixer it was
totally against who i am you know well
ken
you didn't break your last marriage
you didn't break it
and the fact that you couldn't quote
unquote save something that you couldn't
save anyway
doesn't mean you're a failure doesn't
mean you screwed up
i need you to let that go put that down
because you're carrying this narrative
that if you had just said the right
thing or done the right thing that maybe
she would have stayed attracted to you
maybe she
it wasn't going to happen
and you got to set that down because
you've got too much life left and you've
got an amazing woman on the other side
of this thing
waiting for full ken and what i want you
to do is love ken as much as this new
woman loves ken does she love you
yes absolutely tells me constantly shows
me
constantly too
dude can i tell you something you're
worth
being loved and you're worth laughing
i have a great friend she
she's about
probably 15 or 20 years older than me
she had a long-term relationship and
kids were grown and found out there was
some infidelity they got divorced and
then it was a brutal divorce and then
shortly thereafter
her ex got sick and passed away
and
then she got remarried years later and i
was asking her about this process and
she said i built a life with somebody
we raised kids
created a home
i got remarried
because i loved this person
and we were gonna have as much fun as
humanly possible until my days are over
and that subtle shift was such a
powerful statement for me
and how old are you
um almost 55.
dude
you're a little over halfway
and you've got somebody that's going to
get old and wrinkly and ride or die with
you man and y'all can slide into the end
of this thing with no tread left on your
tires
i need you to hear that you're worth
that
do you believe me
i do yeah
all right
say these words
ken's worth loving again
toward 11 again
you just said that all weird like i was
telling you about taxes say ken's worth
loving again i want you to mean it
ken's worth loving again hell yeah dude
yeah ken
now you don't have to marry this girl
but i think you should i think it'd be
awesome
i think you're going to man and it
should be weird and it should be
uncomfortable and it's all still all
right
the only thing i can't i'm going to ask
you to not do is don't keep secrets from
your new wife
when you feel uncomfortable you all come
up with a signal like ah i'm trying to
get nervous
ah
but i love you
and here's what i want you to do when
you get engaged i want you to send me a
picture of that ring on her finger i
want you to send me a picture of the
wedding
you are going to get some weird doodle
dog or something send me a picture of
that
do not get
one of those motorcycle tricycles
you're 55 but you're not
walking dead
and dude i'm excited for you ken i'm
excited for you brother i'm excited for
you
everything in your body is trying to do
it just love you and take care of you
man you gotta tell your body thank you
thank you thank you maybe do this i say
this every single show almost
i want you to write yourself a letter
dear ken
dear ken
go back and walk through
here's what it was like loving somebody
through cancer here's what it's like
finding out that she was cheating on me
here's what it was like trying to hold
everything together
here's what it's like the heartbreak of
divorce of it when it was all over
here's what that grief was like
and then there's a period at the end of
that sentence and then i want you to
turn the page and i want you to then
write and now what
and here's what my life's gonna be i
found a great girl that i've known since
we are next door neighbors dawson's
creek i don't wanna wait and we're going
forward with whatever minutes and hours
we got left we're gonna have the most
fun and we're gonna do it together
you deserve a kin you're worth it
thank you so much for the call